.
THE COMMITTEE HAS THEIR NEXT
HEARING COMING OUT.
>> KATELYN POLANTZ, THANK YOU.
THIS MORNING, RUSSIANS LINING
UP TO FLEE THE NATION AS
LATERAL PUTIN INTENSIFIES
AGAINST UKRAINE.
RUSSIAN FORCES HAVE BEEN DRIVEN
OUT OF THE NEWLY LIBERATED CITY
OF KUPIANSK IN UKRAINE.
THE ECHO OF DANGEROUS SHELLING
NEARBY REMAINS AND THE CITY
MIGHT BE FREE OF THE RUSSIANS
FAR FROM STATE.
AS BEN WEDEMAN REPORTS FROM THE
FRONT LINES.
>> FOR A FEW LOAVES OF BREAD,
RESIDENTS OF KUPIANSK RISK
THEIR LIVES.
UKRAINIAN FORCES RETAKE THE
CITY ABOUT TWO WEEKS AGO, BUT
THE FIGHTING IS FAR FROM OVER.
JULIETTE DESCRIBES IT IN ONE
WORD --
INTENSE.
THAT IS THE ECHO OF CLUSTER
BOMBS FALLING NOT FAR AWAY.
>> [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> SOMETIMES I'M SCARED, SAYS
DANIIL OVER THE SOUND OF NEARBY
SHELLING.
SOMETIMES, I DON'T CARE.
THESE ARE THE FEW PEOPLE LEFT
IN KUPIANSK.
EVEN THOUGH THIS CITY
THEORETICALLY THE RUSSIANS HAVE
LEFT, THE RUSSIANS ARE JUST
ACROSS THE RIVER.
ACCORDING TO THE SOLDIERS HERE,
THERE ARE STILL RUSSIANS INSIDE
THE UKRAINIAN-CONTROLLED PART
OF THE CITY.
RUSSIAN FORCES TOOK CONTROL OF
KUPIANSK WITH A LITTLE FIGHTING
IN THE FIRST DAYS OF THE WAR.
IT SERVED AS THE ADMINISTRATIVE
CENTER FOR THE RUSSIAN OCCUPIED
PART OF THE KHARKIV REGION.
PRO-RUSSIAN SYMPATHIES LINGER
ON HERE.
THE RUSSIANS PAID SALARIES AND
PENSIONS.
THE RECENT UKRAINIAN COUNTER
OFFENSIVE TURNED THIS CITY INTO
A WAR ZONE, SPARKING RESENTMENT
AGAINST BOTH SIDES.
THEY ARE ONE OF THE SAME, SAYS
ONE MAN.
THE MOOD OF THE POPULATION IS
SHOCKED.
IT'S TOO EARLY AND TOO
DANGEROUS.
RECORD IS STILL SCATTERED IN
THE STREETS.
THERE IS A FAIRLY CONSTANT
INCOMING AND OUTGOING ARTILLERY
AND ROCKET FIRE HERE.
>> AN HOURS DRIVE AWAY IN THE
TOWN OF IZYUM, NO SHELLING, BUT
SHELL-SHOCKED STILL SHOW ON THE
FACES OF PEOPLE WAITING FOR
FOOD.
THE FIGHTING HAS MOVED ON.
THIS CAR AS IT LEFT ALREADY.
THEY HIT MY HOME, SAYS
LYUDMYLA.
WAR SPARES NO ONE, AS CATARINA.
THE LOCAL FIRE STATION HAS
BECOME A WAREHOUSE FOR SUPPLIES
DONATED BY --
IN HER GRANDFATHER'S ARMS,
ALINA CALLS INTENSE BOMBING.
IT KILLED OUR DOG AND HIT THE
ROOF.
WE WERE HIDING IN THE BASEMENT,
SHE SAYS.
BACK IN KUPIANSK, TA